mi nombre es con sebastián aguirre con
un creador de imágenes un coleccionista
de historias
y un imaginad ahora tiempo completo
desde la adolescencia pase la vida
intentando encontrar algo que me defina
algo que me haga diferente al resto algo
que me haga único en su momento fue el
skateboarding la música que escuchaba la
ropa que utilizaba o incluso como
llevaba mi pelo
pero entendí que la identidad no es algo
que uno puede quitarse o ponerse sino
que es algo que está intrínseco dentro
de uno y es algo mucho más profundo y se
evidencian las cosas cotidianas como por
ejemplo la manera de hablar y justo esa
fue la primera búsqueda que yo tuve para
entender quién soy primero como quiteño
luego como ecuatoriano y en su momento
como latinoamericana
algo que yo valoro mucho de mi niño
interior es la capacidad de asombro la
curiosidad y un espíritu inquisitivo que
se han mantenido hasta el día de hoy que
me han llevado a cuestionarme muchas
cosas
porque vivimos como vivimos porque
pensamos como pensamos porque hacemos lo
que hacemos y para que nuestro hábitat
por ejemplo debe ser muy distinto a
estos cubos de cemento en los cuales
habitamos la ciudad
cada vez más concreto y menos naturaleza
he tenido la oportunidad de viajar al
interior del país y encontrarme con
comunidades indígenas que tienen casas
en base a la vida están hechas de
plantas y están rodeadas de naturaleza y
es impresionante darse cuenta ese
contraste con la frialdad de la ciudad
que simplemente representa divisiones
que nos aíslan las ciudades que
tienen paredes blancas son ciudades
mudas los graffitis me hacían de alguna
manera cuestionarme si es que estaban
dirigidos hacia mi quien se tomaba el
tiempo de escribir esto
para que lo hacía porque lo hacía en la
calle un día caminando me encontré con
este hombrecito y fue un encuentro que
me marcó la vida porque me di cuenta que
el arte callejero tiene el poder de
humanizar la ciudad que tiende a ser un
sitio tan impersonal y frío como alguien
se toma el tiempo de recoger los pedazos
de chatarra y construirlos con tal amor
que este personaje tenga este gesto y
soltarlo en la calle y no regalárselo a
su mamá o guardarse lo para él mismo fue
algo que me impactó mucho y me dejó una
espinita
en el año 2011 empecé a intervenir la
calle mis primeras intervenciones fueron
súper influenciadas por la estética del
cómic y las proporciones de la
caricatura
muchas de las historias eran
autorreferenciales y me basaban
solamente en mis historias personales
porque es súper fácil hablar desde el yo
los primeros murales surgieron con un
ingrediente que eran estos textos empecé
a indagar en términos del lenguaje
entendiendo que el como hablamos habla
mucho de dónde somos entonces empecé a
retratar este castellano lindísimo que
hablamos aquí en el ecuador
la ley ahora tocará esperar
sipse se animó a lejos
me muero yo sos
ando con un sueño que parecen 2
estas frases y refranes y dichos
están inspirados en la gente común y
corriente
las voy recogiendo en mis cuadernos de
las conversaciones ajenas que escucho en
la ciudad en las filas de los bancos en
los buses
y nos hablan de un mestizaje entre unos
términos sismos y también castellano y
nos hablan como nos hable a la gente
nos habla desde la realidad son textos
que vienen desde otras generaciones de
mi abuelo por ejemplo cuando se siente
me cuenta sus anécdotas sus chistes
de alguna manera siento nostalgia porque
todo este tipo de cosas se van
desvaneciendo
pero la nostalgia es algo que paraliza
para mí es importante tomar un poco el
pasado licuarlo en el presente y en base
a eso pensar en el futuro dicen que una
imagen vale más que mil palabras pero
cuando la imagen logra hablarte en tus
palabras algo mágico sucede
una de las cosas importantes también que
cabe recalcar de mis obras de esta época
en las que utilizaba texto es que las
letras son super legibles a diferencia
de la tradición del graffiti en las que
las letras adquieren curvas como en el
wild style y la mayoría de gente no las
entiende en mi caso yo busco llegar a
más gente yo busco que mi arte sea
inclusivo y que lo pueda entender tanto
un anciano como una niña chiquita un
ejecutivo que va rápidamente
en su coche o la señora que vende comida
en la calle
cuando empecé a pintar en la calle me
salí totalmente de lo que yo estaba
acostumbrada
salí de mi zona de confort porque
necesitaba explorar estos nuevos campos
porque una cosa es
dibujar dentro de tu estudio donde
tienes control de la luz del clima si te
da frío te pones tu mantita te sirves
una taza de café
dibujar en un cuaderno de bocetos es
súper fácil te vas de la esquina
superior a la esquina inferior sólamente
moviendo la mano pero otra cosa es
cuando sales de la calle y te toca
enfrentarte con la gran escala con
paredes que son mucho más grandes que tú
y ya no es solamente mover la manito
sino que tienes que subir y bajar un
andamio y a veces estás en la cima y
dices tú también me del rojo
a bajar de mes
una cosa súper importante de entender es
que a diferencia de la pintura de
caballete o el
o el trabajo en el taller los lienzos en
la calle ya tienen su propia
personalidad ya tienen una vida previa
antes de que tú vayas y no intervengas
no es como el lienzo que es cuadrado
pulcro y perfecto
son incluso espacios que tienen un
contexto que están en una situación
geográfica de la ciudad que tienen
personajes que transitan por ahí a
diario y el hecho de que tú cambies de
ese espacio
y genera una conversación con ellos y
siempre trato de conversar con la gente
del lugar y entender el contexto de la
pared porque pienso que es una
responsabilidad colocar una imagen en el
espacio público y que esa imagen diálogo
con la gente que está ahí
el arte urbano me ha enseñado a
disfrutar del proceso y no solamente de
la imagen final el mural de alguna
manera tiene también un carácter
colectivo
se nutre mucho del contexto y puede
visibilizar a personas que sin este
mecanismo permanecería en él
en la invisibilidad la pared que uno
interviene tiene vida y dialoga con uno
y uno muchas veces está en este proceso
y llega a gente que llegan para aportar
en este en este tema y uno pensaría que
al terminar la obra a veces toman cuatro
días a veces toma un día tres horas y al
terminar la obra la obra está lista pero
no es así el momento en el que uno
termina la obra es como dar a luz esta
obra ya no me pertenece esta obra le
pertenece a la ciudad tiene una vida
propia
mira caras nuevas todos los días se
envejece con el tiempo sus colores se
desvanecen
a causa de la lluvia y el sol
sin contar incluso con la intervención
de las personas que muchas veces pueden
intervenir lo
y a veces en el peor de los casos pueden
taparlo también
las obras que yo pinto en la calle están
inspiradas en las personas que la
habitan
y eso es lo que permite que exista esta
relación y esta conversación esta
conversación puede llegar a ser tan
estrecha que incluso el peatón y la
pintura pueden empezar a dialogar
visualmente como fue el caso de esta
obra en la que un borracho vino y le
pintó un bigote a uno de mis personajes
que estaban recién afeitaditos y en
lugar de tapar la obra y pintar otra
cosa como normalmente lo haría decidí
aceptar su sugerencia yo pinto
personajes del día a día personajes
que pueden tener actos heroicos desde su
realidad
pero están muy lejanos al estereotipo de
superhéroe que nosotros tenemos en la
mente yo les denominó antihéroes porque
un antihéroe es súper distinto a un
villano un antihéroe es un héroe no
convencional
que puede tener actos heroicos desde su
realidad
es una persona genuina que no se rige
bajo los estándares que la sociedad le
impone
estos murales inspirados en el día a día
nos muestran que las pequeñas cosas el
cotidiano tiene también un valor que a
simple vista no lo tendría porque
contaría uno una historia tan sencilla
como ésta si puede contar cosas
historias en las que explotan cosas y la
gente vuela
y existen dispositivos de altísima
tecnología yo escojo volver a la persona
simple
el tesoro de lo cotidiano como yo le
llamo
hoy en día vivimos en un mundo
globalizado que tiende
hacer que nuestras tradiciones
desaparezcan
por que homogeniza el planeta y hace que
todos queramos escuchar la misma música
vestirnos de la misma manera y comer las
mismas cosas
nos hace pensar
la naturaleza es simplemente
un dispositivo que uno puede explotar
para conseguir más dinero
en contraste a esto está por ejemplo la
cosmovisión andina
que denomina la naturaleza como su madre
pachamama y se relaciona con ella a
través de permisos ofrendas gratitud y
rituales
he tenido la oportunidad de viajar a
españa y sentirme identificado con su
cultura por causa de nuestra cultura que
todavía tiene lejos de colonialismo
pero siendo un mestizo que es consciente
de los orígenes de su mezcla he decidido
abrazar con orgullo mi raíz indígena
por toda esta cosmovisión y cómo se
relaciona con el planeta
y ese sentido de pertenencia nos
empodera para poder enfrentar un planeta
que cada vez está más despersonalizado y
estas pequeñas sutilezas y estas
tradiciones y estas creencias se
desvanecen en un mundo en el que todo
quiere que seamos personas grises que
piensen igual
yo me siento orgulloso de ser
ecuatoriano me siento orgulloso de haber
nacido en quito en la mitad del mundo y
poder hablar desde aquí de todos estos
temas y reconocerme no como un quiteño
sino como un habitante del mundo
entendiendo que el continente entero fue
dividido por repúblicas con líneas
imaginarias que lo único que quieren es
enemistarnos y hacer que odiamos al
vecino cuando las culturas ancestrales
presentaban una transición orgánica de
pensamiento de tradiciones de lenguas a
lo largo de todo el continente y todos
eran concebidos como hermanos y existía
una relación de trueques
y de intercambios que hacían que
realmente todos avancen no como ahora
que no sabíamos entre nosotros y nos
ponemos bravos y nos vienen a visitar
nuestros hermanos colombianos
[Aplausos]
es súper triste ver como fuimos criados
nosotros con un sistema educativo que
nos inculcó el auto racismo y nos hizo
sentir avergonzados por todo lo
referente a lo indio cuando en realidad
deberíamos estar orgullosos de tener ese
contacto con la siembra con el sol con
las estrellas con las plantas es
inconcebible que un indígena sea rico
sabio se comunique con todo su entorno
en medio de la selva y por causa de la
minería se ve obligado a abandonar su
entorno para venir a la ciudad y el
momento en el que pisa la ciudad se
transforme en un analfabeto desempleado
y pobre
yo me pregunto si la sabiduría implica
saber leer un libro por ejemplo
para mí la sabiduría también puede ser
la tradición oral la historia viva de
nuestro continente que cada vez es menor
y menor la zona intangible del yasuní
ahora creo que es de este porte
todo esto toda esta línea de pensamiento
en relación a rescatar mi raíz me hizo
entender
que el mural es el mural tiene muchas
más capas que solamente pintar una
imagen bonita hay gente que se acerca y
me dice gracias por adornar mi ciudad
pero el mural no es solamente un
ornamento el mural es un mecanismo de
comunicación
y fue ahí que decidí salir a pintar esta
obra
mucha gente se cree que está haciendo
activismo social o activismo político
por escribir un tuit cómodamente desde
su celular
pero yo les invito a que salgamos a la
calle también y tomemos de acción que
hagamos de expresa nuestra voz y manera
de hacerlo es pintando murales deje de
hablar y comience a hacer
cuando pinte esta obra un niño rodeado
de ratas durmiendo en la calle se me
acercó una señora y me dice joven porque
está pintando esas barbaridades tan feas
y yo le digo señora lo que pasa es que
la televisión y las noticias no se toman
la molestia de comunicar estas cosas que
están sucediendo y todos nos hacemos de
la vista gorda
como fue el caso de guayaquil
tuve la oportunidad de pintar un mural
de seis pisos de altura en el centro
financiero de guayaquil
en la zona bancaria al lado de la
policía y es un mural que representa el
círculo vicioso de la corrupción
vino la comunidad afro y me denunció
porque dicen que soy un racista
porque se enfocan en un pedacito de la
imagen y no se dan cuenta acaso que este
hombre es mestizo y tiene la piel igual
de morena que yo
pero el tema es que tiene una media
nylon que oscurece su rostro y esconde
su identidad y se agarraron de eso para
denunciar me fuimos a la defensoría del
pueblo y se demostró que no existía una
mala intención simplemente estoy
poniendo en la cara de todos algo que no
les gusta ver y es súper feo a veces
verse al espejo
es importante que nos tomemos el tiempo
de entender que el mural no está sólo
para entretener sino también para
llevarnos a reflexionar mostrándonos
realidades que existen porque no
solamente es ladrón el chorro de
cuchillo y chancleta sino también es el
ladrón de corbata y cuello blanco
y me atrevo a decir que todos los que
estamos aquí o la mayoría somos parte de
este círculo de la corrupción porque no
hace falta robarte millones de dólares
de una cuenta bancaria es simple con
saltarse un puesto en la fila del banco
o pasar o hacer doble fila en una en una
curva ya estamos siendo parte de esto
porque estamos torciendo las reglas a
nuestro favor
y para finalizar les voy a contar esta
historia del último mural que pinte
en el 2013 pinte junto con unos amigos
de este mural en un terreno baldío y la
gente pasaba y decía eso sí es arte
y otros pasaban y decían anda manchar la
casa de tu abuela hombre malcriado
y existen reacciones distintas a veces
me dan algo de comer o de tomar y otras
veces hasta me han caído chancletas
aquí podemos ver cómo tenemos una
pintura mural que se blanqueó con la
venida del papa en el 2015 y después
tuvo presencia el grafiti cuando yo la
quise pintar vinieron 17 policías
armados a impedirlo y esto se debió a
que el contenido que yo estaba
comunicando era un poco incisivo
con este mural yo quise mostrar tres
alternativas para expresar un
sentimiento en común que es el amor
y vinieron vecinos enojados a querer
intervenir la obra primero le pusieron
unas cruces y luego le echaron pintura y
para mí es impresionante la cantidad de
odio que puede existir y como la no
tolerancia nos hace actuar también para
querer borrar lo que no queremos ver y
no se dan cuenta que por borrar el mural
no no van a dejar de existir estas
minorías que fueron favorecidas con la
legalización del matrimonio igualitario
mucha gente dirá aseguró que era irás
porque tú estás pintando algo y vienen y
te tapan les digo que me encanta que
esto suceda porque esto es evidencia de
que vivimos en una sociedad que no le
gusta cuestionarse que no le gusta salir
de su caja de mente no está lista quizás
por este tipo de expresiones decidieron
borrar a las dos parejas homosexuales y
dejar intacta la a la pareja
heterosexual como si lo demás no
existiera
yo no vengo a hablar aquí ni a imponer
pensando en que yo tengo la razón
simplemente estoy entablando una
conversación y es muy interesante que
esto pase lo triste es que este tipo de
intervenciones de iniciativas de
autogestionadas terminan así y dan
inicio a través del ciclo
es importante que no nos demos cuenta
que en un mundo globalizado como hoy
el tener un cuestionamiento hacia
nuestra identidad y entender que desde
cualquiera sea el sitio que ustedes
estén pueden hacer algo es un acto
revolucionario gracias